Without a ribber,
adding both knit and Purl stitches
on a flatbed machine takes a bit of work.
You need to reform individual stitches
to create ribbing
and textured stitch patterns.
One of the first techniques that many
machine knitters learn
is called mock ribbing.
This is a hem that imitates ribbing
without it reforming any stitches.
If you haven't
tried this, please do.
It's very quick and easy, and it's a great
technique to have in your bag of tricks.
Get started by casting
on with every other needle.
I used an E-Wrap cast on because
it's nice and stretchy.
Now make sure that the empty needles are
in out of work position and knit twice
the desired length of your ribbing.
Now, pick up the cast on edge and hang
the loops of your cast
on into the emptied needles.
When you're done,
all the needles will have stitches,
and all the needles are in work.
Now
for our swatch here,
knit a few rows or continue knitting
your garment and just bind off.
The secret to nice mock
rib is in the finishing.
Now, once you've removed your work
from the machine, insert a pencil or ruler
or a straight knitting needle
into to the hem, into the fold there,
and give it a pull to set the stitches.
The knitting contracts
and gives the appearance of ribbing
without a lot of muss and fuss.
Many knitters forget about this technique,
and it's quick and easy, and again,
it's a nice technique to keep
in your bag of tricks.
Now, some knitters will cast on with waist
yarn and ravel cord for this technique,
and when they're ready to hang the hem,
they pick up the first row of stitches
and put them on the empty needles.
Try it both ways and see
which method you prefer.